it's Wednesday afternoon in in lovely
sunny Europe I'm Sparky Munich Germany
I'm joined by Matt and Nick in London UK
oh it's three o'clock here in Munich
it's two o'clock in London and we're
here to talk about Android app
development so with that I see that
we've got Andrew Kelly in the Hangout
and he's also had a question prepared
for us I don't know if I have the answer
but let's hear it I had two questions
today actually one was to do with the
action bar and the overflow menu items
on things like ginger beard whenever I
used the Menu key
I saw the high of Menu key on a device I
can see a little icon next to each of
the items in the menu but on Gingerbread
and sorry on Ice Cream Sandwich and
jelly bean those icons seem to disappear
I was just wondering if that's
intentional or a bug in my code no
that's what he is intended okay cool you
know any reason why they decided to get
rid of those I mean I I don't know you
put it's probably question for the UX
team but they decided that if their menu
would just be textual okay I was a
simple answer yeah look at the moderator
I believe that I I hit upon the correct
answer right away which was to say I'll
let Nick answer this and there it was
yeah you can I've seen other
applications override it and do more
interesting menus I think chrome for
example there's some stuff where it puts
the first overflow item is actually you
know three it's the forward and back and
start buttons I think so they've done
something a little bit more creative
with iconography so it's possible to
kind of override the implementation and
do something with I clocked with us
super important to you but I'd probably
stick to the 2,000 default unless you
have good reasons to deviate nice way to
make sure it wasn't a bug that's all I
have to say that putting reserving the
icons for the action bar gives you I
think maybe a little more incentive to
put your your your colorful and
interesting actions out there and not
hide them in the overflow well
I don't know yeah it's also quite
important to provide text and icons for
everything because the way the action
bar works with the if room and so on you
just don't you can't guarantee
deterministically how many icons are
going to be shown depending on the
device and platform changes and all this
good stuff so yes is super important to
provide a title even if you only even if
you just have an icon and you say always
show this because you know that that
same title text will be used for the
long press tooltip so it's just really
important to provide provide both really
well you've you've got the floor amend
read you want to enter as your other
question whilst I'm here as well and
I'll just try to work out if there's a
way of doing animated Launcher icons or
icons that can change on maybe a given
dates like a calendar app might have an
icon that would say the third the second
you know the actual date would be part
of the the launcher icon
I just don't work out if there was a
clever way of other animating Launcher
icons or having them change over time so
there's no built-in support for this
there's no like API for this there you
could probably do something clever slash
evil by using package manager dot enable
set component enabled so if you think
about it your application is just you
know the icon in the launcher is just a
intent receiver for the home script home
main intent filters right so I guess you
could create 31 of those each of which
points to the same activity but has a
different icon defined and then have
some kind of alarm which uses packet
manager to enable disable I've of course
nukes that sounds it sounds like a hack
and it's probably going to break things
like if you try and put a shortcut well
it's not probably it will break things
if you try and put a shortcut on your
home screen for example in disabling the
component which you usually drop from
the home screen and everything another
one which looks similar it you know it's
gonna break it it's probably breaking
all kinds of over a handful of hours you
could do it but probably not I probably
would say
think about maybe having a widget so
obviously we won't change in the law in
the launcher in the all apps tray but on
the home screen you could have an icon
which changed daily say and get close
enough yeah I've done that work out if
there's a way I could sort of extends
the animated drawable and ought to have
it automatically called the start method
on the animation and just point to that
in my sort of manifest XML file or
something but I was there yeah
unsuccessful trying to get that kind of
thing to work yeah I'm not surprised the
DEP unisys footage ease case for I'd be
curious to find out if some of the
third-party launcher replacements do
that or if they support that capability
today we're having camera hunting
problems here I who else we've got
joined us is that pull yes um all Hanson
is on the Hangout welcome Paul what's up
hello you hear me okay yeah never tell
if you're working because I've got the
video feed no things are good thank you
for getting back to me Nick the other
day I've just been spending all quite a
while trying to get a VM up and running
with the code so it's taking me a while
to get try get proper VM done so I'm
gonna implement that quite soon mm-hmm
otherwise I've got a few things to ask
but they're not in a very easy to ask
format so I might hang on until later in
the in the show okay
I know presume I see you're doing a talk
Nick or the the developer conference
next week which one
the droidcon is there another one in
London no next week I'm gonna be there
I'm just as an attendee droidcon I won't
be speaking Matt hey we'll be talking
yep also topic um Samaras just a new
specialty over TV and at the moment I'm
probably gonna be doing some stuff on
the anymote protocol and I'm looking
forward to meeting everybody and meeting
up with some Google types down there
cool awesome yeah I'll just be hanging
out meet you guys talking
Android ever guess Oh brilliant yeah
should be good come say hi yeah I
definitely will I want to I've got a few
more things at NFC to send you a message
before the conference because you I know
you got your contact and those all these
things yes okay yeah sure why not
cheers I'll definitely see you next week
cool and if you feel free if you do and
ask questions I would much rather take
live questions from a person who can
clarify and respond and make sure we're
on the right track then go through okay
yeah I've got one okay one thing I'm say
I'm not got it fully prepared this time
because I was on holiday last week one
question I do have it generally is
Google or Android have been preparing
for trusted execution environments as
that ring any bells of anybody things
like um trust zone and things like this
yeah I've got some specs I've got to
read because I mean I do a lot of
research and I can see this is a
important area they're still different
looks like they're still defining the
actual specs at the moment but I'll
pursue him and Reuter getting fully
behind it sort of thing do you know if
you're lucky not not any specifics I my
general my general read on that is that
that kind of thing is not very googley
but if you are going to be doing media
codecs and and playing back licensed
content from people who own media titles
are you gonna have to go there okay yeah
so at the moment my take on it it's not
a subject I know a ton about but I
believe there are some devices already
supported like in the silicone already
and in the market like the Galaxy s3 and
so forth and I think in some cases we
even take advantage of it I think maybe
in some of our DRM stuff I'm not
entirely sure but I don't think there's
any platform api's yet I think it's all
quite device specific at the moment okay
are you gonna be invoking native
libraries and so on so you mentioned the
galaxy s3 what was what was was in
relation to the galaxy s
where you just mentioned sorry I missed
that bit sorry I think they support the
arm trust zone somehow whether I'm not
entirely sure okay I think I just had
that anecdotally yes okay no problem
okay Braden oh I have some stuff I write
and message over before the conference
so that or is there someone at the
conference there might be more
NFC a more security kind of person down
there and nothing Google now okay okay
cool any more live questions or are we
gonna take a dive into the moderator
queue since you since you brought it up
before maybe you would like to take a
minute to tell us what you did last
weekend and what is that thing on the
wall behind you yeah absolutely and I
was visiting friends in Berlin this
weekend who were holding a dev fest
event really nice little event which was
an interfacer lots of also talks about
Google technologies coupled with an
Android V hack event as well so this is
celebrating androids fifth birthday
there's a bunch of hackathons going
around going on culminating in a final
and hackathon in London after droidcon
and one of the one of the cool extra
things around androids birthday is
Murray Feiss the awesome designer has
painted over my shoulder just about a
game board so it's like a snakes and
ladders style game where you move around
from start to in depicting the life of
androids they've got cupcakes and
gingerbread men and eclairs all this
good stuff in there so you can move
around and you can have slide back down
the honeycomb trail and so on and it's
beautiful
and I know she's trying to get this
turned into a game right yep
so if you go to github.com slash sea
bass sea ba se or maybe C - ba se sure
there's an open-source project where
they're I think using an engine to turn
this into a playable game on your tablet
so you can have you know people Penske
so if you if you have any spare time or
you know you came to a hackathon and
don't know what hak'tyl
then perhaps you can contribute they'll
be awesome present to you to the Android
community Oh play and it goes to all the
platform /c - base cool so then it's
called what birthday if Android birthday
something ok
I think it's that happy 5th birthday
cool but yeah I'm sure all patches
welcome
yeah I think Murray just wants to see
that bad boy go out really I think yeah
if you need assets yeah I think if you
pink hair you'll probably get response
pretty quick good well thanks for the
update I shall we take a moderator
question then reaches place to the link
github.com /c - bae / happy - v -
birthday - android Oh
Gary's buggy
okay so first unanswered question on the
moderator activity hosting multiple
fragments each fragment uses data from
the same table of a local database would
it be better to load table data into a
singleton pojo in activity rather than
loaders in each fragment
how can activity broadcast fragments
unload complete he this is Martin as he
goes on to say I know how to use
interface methods to access data in
activity from the fragment I just don't
know how the activity can tell the
fragment it's loaded the data so the
fragment can hide the indeterminate
progress and paint the data maybe loader
is not that much of a problem when each
fragment needs the data from web service
then it makes sense for the activity to
do a single web service call so this
sounds like kind of a familiar design
pattern to me you've got you've got a
data store you want to show it in
possibly multiple places each and a
fragment and you've got this very long
slow method of getting the data from the
web which could take an indeterminate
long time it could take seconds or even
minutes to fetch the data this is this
kind of follows I think in the pattern
of like the RSS reader
that I wrote earlier this year and what
I did to solve the problem in that case
was I use a sequel database to host the
data locally I used a content provider
to publish it and then loaders wait so
that the the loaders and the content
provider worked out between themselves
when the data needed to be refreshed in
that case my my fragments really didn't
have to do a whole lot now it is true
that I did not I did not put any code
into my detail fragment to look for a
change in the data because I was
expecting the data to be quite static
but the ListView definitely updated
dynamically as as the database changed I
did not do an indeterminate progress
instead basically I just fetched
everything more or less invisibly and
just let the new data magically appear
in the ListView what I did for fetching
the data was not to put it in the
activity but I put it in an intent to
service and then either a timer kicked
off by alarm manager or a user interface
button on the action bar would cause an
intent to be sent to the intent service
to go out to the web data store and and
fetch new data for me so my answer then
was intent service for the web kicked
off by intents from the activity or from
alarmmanager sequel database to hold the
data content provider to front loader to
keep it fresh and then one fragment per
to to actually show the data rather
long-winded explanation but I don't see
a lot of other people vying for our
attention here and yeah just speaking
about the general question you said
about how would you have the activity
talk to a fragment so yeah he says he
understands that you can use an
interface method that the activity
implements so that when the fragment
gets the unattached message it holds a
reference and costs the activity to that
interface so understands talking from
the fragment up to the activity but
quite simply the answer is really simple
really like a I think it's fine for the
activity to know concrete details about
the fragment it's just not okay for the
fragment to know concrete details about
the activity as
because that destroys the idea of me I
had to lay out the fragments differently
but because because activities own the
fragments within them it's okay to
directly in call method so you can just
you know when you create that fragment
and add it to the page and a transaction
you just hold it a reference set
fragment and just invoke methods upon it
so you could just if you did decide to
try the loader help by the activity
rather than a load of fragment you could
just invoke methods directly on the
fragment itself that's good to me shall
we move on to the next moderator
question the next one is this question
from Andrew Kelly about the action bar I
think we've heard that one already
okay here's now here's here's kind of a
tempting one I HTC just announced a five
inch phone with a 1920 by 1080 pixel
resolution screen so 1080p this leads to
420 dots four hundred and forty dots per
inch one openness work and how can
developers provide drawables for this
resolution X HTTP is 320 and this is 100
DPI more 120bpm where how big is the
screen size and dips for this phone so
my my first response to this question
was oh my god I want this phone I i I've
provided a link to it in the I provided
a link to HTC's product description and
it is a very very nice looking phone I
have to say right so my so first off you
know that dips basically translate to
real world units it's sort of a
shorthand for approximately inches or
some fraction thereof and and that 160
dots per inch is the the natural
standard for a dip so at 160 dpi your
one bit per pixel
generally speaking phone devices fall
into the normal size bucket
there it there is a bit of overlap in
our bucket sizes so that a large phone
in a small tablet could be either
normal-sized or large size generally
speaking you want your small tablets to
be in the large size bucket and you want
your big phones to still be in the
normal size bucket I think so I don't
have any any direct information on this
phone at all other than just looking at
HTC's press release but I would guess
that at this pixel count just 1920 by
1080 you're looking at approximately
speaking 360 dips by 640 dips and it'll
probably fall into the xxhdpi density
bucket which is something that was added
to the Android SDK for for SDK level 16
wait hang on so but xxxx is what full
480 dpi xx a yes exit is hex xhdpi is
480 dots per inch so the pro you
wouldn't get the xxxx turbos because
it's not high enough
well it's a beautiful back to xhdpi
drove alright we're always a little bit
flexible rate I mean it's it's sort of
it's it's not precisely but it's the
it's the closest density bucket that
matches the actual density of the screen
I think that you know 480 is a lot
closer to 440 than is 320 which is the
next available size huh that's what it
was so it's kind of my that's kind of my
take on it is that I thought he would
never round up I thought he would only
other round down I'm with spiking this
one I think the documentation always
suggests is roughly I'll go around that
but I'm gonna have to go and look at
this source code to display manager
another thing that I noted is that it's
approximately it's approximately twice
I'm sorry 440 dpi it's approximately
twice the density of TB dpi so if you
have T V dpi assets they could just
about be doubled and would just about
fit the idea scaring any
up scares the bejesus out of me yes but
that's but that said I mean if you if
you don't provide asset weight density
goes down you'll never scare that's what
I'm think of yeah you're right it will
take the 480 as I scale them down like
right but so you write an app that's
targeted at you know normal deep it's a
medium dpi and you run it on your Galaxy
Nexus it's gonna have to take that low
res asset and display it on the high res
display so it's going to have to do some
doubling and am I just sort of my
general take on in this is if I'm gonna
have to be scaling up an icon or
something
I would rather double it then multiply
it by one point five because I think
you're going to have fewer banding and
artifacts and things like that and the
other thing that's worth noting as well
is that the density buckets are
basically just aliases so I think at
runtime a apt will just turn them into
numbers right so when you have drawable
- hdpi actually turns that at runtime
into drawable - 240 dpi so you can
actually provide numeric qualifiers so
if supporting a device with 440 DPI is
super important to you and your launcher
icon has to look you know amazingly
crisp on that device create a version at
the native resolution and put it in the
drawable - 440 DPI and follow a
brilliant suggestion like thank you but
generally I would say you only ever want
to be scaling down so if you know what
you're doing you can you can get pretty
good effects by just providing say xhdpi
graphics and have that scaled down to
hdpi and mdpi devices by sticking to
like a 4 pixel rhythm like 4 pixel major
grid and not having kind of very small
elements you know it so they can be hard
or quartet and relatively smoothly can
help you get a lot of the way but
there's no substitute for actually you
know
producing the right assets in different
densities and I boiling them and
checking that they're correct and
especially being careful on nine patches
because if you provide a nine patch in
just one like higher resolution and it
gets scaled down by the system to run on
say an L DVI device you got to be real
careful with your stretchable regions if
you only used to say one or two pixels
for your stretchable region that might
get downsampled and run down to zero
pixels for example and all the sudden
your nice patch doesn't stretch no yeah
you want to make sure your stretchable
areas or I think two or four I think
four pixels would be the safest pretty
much density but there's no substitute
for producing proper densities
especially for critical assets like Lord
Dragon's right and it's been my general
observation that photographs scale up
and down through density is really
really well but but finally hand-drawn
line art like what you typically get on
icons doesn't scale so well so you know
for these for these little visual assets
like icons and widgets just go ahead and
make them in the right in the right
pixel sizes in the first place and of
course now that we're we've potentially
got what five fighting weight let's see
low medium high extra high t-v and
double X so we have six potential
density buckets scalable vector graphics
please no I've actually I've actually
put this question to the framework
engineers why can't we just have SVG as
a first class drawable and it's just not
that simple it would be really nice but
it's not that simple there's some
rudimentary support in that library
right the Android SVG project which I
think was created for Android apply the
Android apply application I think they
guys created it and open source it which
is very cool so that actually turns an
SVG into native drawable right right and
if I understand correctly that's that
implements only part of the SVG spec but
if it's the right part I'll take it
well I think we thoroughly answer that
question I hope so
Yann Susan Brazil who is in our hangout
last week if I recall so how can i
launch turn-by-turn navigation from my
application using intents it can be done
it's not a publicly documented API
especially with regards to Google Maps
Navigation that's definitely not public
so we can't really talk about it but we
can at least observe that other people
say it can be done and Stack Overflow is
your friend very very nicely done
weasel weasel how can I say I used to be
a weasel keeper weasel words are my
specialty
the other thing you can do is a launch
to maps to destination we try to
navigate too because that is a
documented API that is on that on our
developer site and then let the user hit
that navigate to this place button
themselves it's an alternative I think
that's a very nice alternative and
anything that has documented EDI as part
of it is a good answer I love stuff
which links me out to maps anything
talking about places I really love stuff
the legs me out too
we're not just maps but using the new
geo intent right because then other
applications can converge on that like
Google Earth for example also offers to
satisfy those similar intents but it
just means that every time Maps gets
better then your app gets better kind of
thing I love it it's pretty cool let's
see next next question in the in the
moderator is Andrews question about the
animated launcher icon which we covered
at the beginning of the show there's an
interesting one in the Google+ stream oh
please do tell um I have a question
regarding mixer 7 from Ferran Garriga la
sorry if I pronounced that wrong because
I probably have my objective is that
from the native contacts
when I click the call button on a
contact with a telephone number my
application should pop up as an option
for processing the call this is working
on all phones except the Nexus 7 which
doesn't receive the event this is
something that I need to do special for
Nexus 7 now that's an interesting one
this is super phone and goes yes the
next trying it out as skypes you to do
it so they've included the intemperate
that they've got and they're catching
cool privilege and they're trying to
catch the data the data scheme tell so
so it seems to be possible I just tried
it on my device and it's quite popped up
an offer to execute the call for me so
it makes me sit makes me think that
there's something someone ovarian filter
you're not sewing what I would recommend
doing is there's an open source
application called sip droid try it out
on the Nexus 7 see if that catches it if
it does then perhaps you can see what
filters they're using that's what I used
when I'd see something similar to this
because there are quite a few that they
use so remember which ones but yeah this
one means specific well though I have
actually used this kind of ugly app on
the Vice called like intent hunter or
intent something where you could install
only device and it'll tell you which
intent filters your applications you
have installed satisfied so you might be
able to use something like this to look
at it's quite essentially it's a public
API so I don't know if hand but there's
some pointers that might get you going
good idea you've just been joined in the
Hangout by Richard I can't read your
last name I'm sorry Richard but a
hangout can you can you hear me oh okay
perfect
firstly I'm from I'm from Zambia it's an
African country and I and I just got
into Android I like the way it's so
structured because these days we have
software which is not really structured
you just have just of people building it
with
no we don't in with no sense of
structure that's there and I like the
way Android does it cause when
somebody's when somebody's developing in
Android they they are forced to have
structure so that's that's what I what
I'm safe for now would you like to share
with us what you're working on I am
working on a social networking
application using NFC because I like the
idea of I could be able to share
something on your wall just by touching
your phone I just I wouldn't I would
like to try to try that out actually are
you using the the the Android Beam API
for that yes yes Android Beam API but
I'm just I'm just mapping it out to get
the requirements first then and dive
deep into it well let us let us
introduce you to Paul Hanson who is
right next to you in the icon bar at the
bottom of my screen who is an NSC fellow
traveler oh hello hello how's it going q
thank you it sounds quite interesting
your project with the NFC have you
actually implement too much NFC before
no actually my first experience it would
be also like a learning experience or
did you hear me okay for that sorry oh
yes I did
yes I'm still learning it the
limitations of restrictions or were far
we can go with it for future projects so
it it's interesting your angle on it as
well oh yes I was listening in before
sorry yeah yeah I feel like it's uh it's
a growing technology because I think
it's going to be used in so many places
and the ideas you can come up with are
just phenomenal
yeah from a UX point of view like I
think
you can really I really love the way
that Android Beam is implemented and
that there's you know no on-screen
affordance you literally just touch and
then it'll send whatever is in the
foreground I love that simplicity that
you know basically you're using such a
close location as a really strong signal
that you don't have to kind of like you
know have lots of guides and buttons and
things the hint of it actually been
asked about that element of the being we
have to touch on the interface and one
of the I've been asked say is a way of
transferring via NFC without the touch
obviously the beam will force you to
make the person touch but there are some
circumstances where you might want to do
a back and forth conversation and you
may want to may not want to touch each
time but I think it being forces each
time yes if you're using beam like beam
is like a convenience API on top of NFC
so yeah if you want to use beam then
yeah the touch is part of that but you
can obviously build that kind of pain
from that kind of translating behavior
using a lower level and a seat at
yourself yes that's why I was looking at
because that was the only way to do that
yes thank you no I'll just got a
question for it was it Richard in Zambia
I just wondered how many phones actually
have the NFC chip in in your country at
the moment or do you know how how about
the take-up is I am actually doing
school in Canada at the moment okay so I
wouldn't be too sure about it but I
could find out okay well actually in
Canada how much what percentage is is to
take out very high on the the phones
with the NFC chips in at the moment I
guess I it should be pretty high cuz I'm
in the in the place that I'm living in
it's a small town called Kamloops just
like everybody wants to have the newest
phone and it's like almost everybody's
mesmerised by that galaxy galaxy
commercial like oh my god the touch in
phones that is really really cool
so I think a large percentage should
have that okay
good news is it seems to be getting
built into mostly system-on-a-chip setup
so most phones these days or at least
the high-end one seems to be coming with
it anyway yeah I think you're good
it's I'm sort of going out on a limb a
little bit here but I I'm I suspect that
a lot of it it's just a matter of a sort
of economies of manufacturer where
you're gonna want to concentrate your
analog electronics all in one place
which means you're going to want to have
all your different radio your processors
on the same chip and once you're doing
that you've got your telephone baseband
in your Wi-Fi and your Bluetooth all on
the same chip I just saw Walter on the
NFC too and just be done with it mm-hmm
yeah the one thing I haven't spent much
time playing around with is that the new
NFC cards we stay announced that while
ago I've managed to grab a small batch
of those lazy guys of the night they
were quite fun wandering around I think
I got pork off quite in Chester with the
cake droid I think he wanted a set for
them but yeah it seems to be a lot of
people are playing around with NSE and
seeing what they can do with their say
can you tell me can you tell me a bit
about those cards what are they exactly
called please so there's a company
called MU which is in the US as well as
the UK nickel and they do customized
business classical thing with a wish you
can kind of print like a different image
on the front of each card but yeah
they're playing around with NSC I don't
think it's released yet I think so oh
really cool I wasn't sure if they've
released if it yeah go check them out
there
they seem like a pretty cool kind of
product I think there I cut my which
down there I go one of the standard I
think there might be my fair although
I'm probably wrong but they're super
standard card and they're they're not
locks as well so they're read rice ball
so you can use lxb tagwriter app for
example just to push different stuff and
one of the cool things about move their
manufacturing process is that they can
put different tags in different cards as
well which is kind of cool so you can
get like five different designs like
this one has my contact details on this
one has a Google Maps link to get
utilize my office and this one has a
YouTube playlist URL whatever like
pretty cool
nice so I've pasted the URL for them in
the sidebar here it's it's us that mu
dot-com slash can I see good British
company so moderate a question given one
we're getting down there there's not a
whole lot left yes I think this is the
new one this was so this was submitted
since the hangout started so I didn't
answer it in ListView I have custom rows
with progress bars and buttons on each
how can I get info from the row the
button was pressed to start some
calculations of dick progress bar in
this row similar behavior like google
play out we get this kind of a lot I I
see a lot of questions in Stack Overflow
that are all talking about wanting to
put buttons into their list views so
it's a pretty popular pattern I don't
know my first response is why would you
do that
I mean every you know why would you
replicate a control over and over and
over again like that when you could just
make the list the list view clickable
but I think it's a I guess the answer is
just a custom layout right he's already
doing that I think my son's it I think
he wants to know how he knows what the
index is once the buttons been clicked
so I think my default behavior to self
this is if you're using the view holder
pan stash the index in the view holder
and then when the button is clicked
catch the click in the view holder and
then have a separate listener which
passes out saying this is the index of
what I am and I've just been clicked but
yeah I'm kind of with you Sparky it's
not a good thing to do no I don't know
about that I think there's definite ways
you would want a button in their
different clickable regions think about
in the people up for example you have a
list item which is partly your phone
number so tapping you know some type of
it will call them and there's
a little divider and then like the SMS
button I think this is a common pattern
where you have multiple actions per row
I think it's perfectly valid so yeah
you're basically wanted response to the
click but if you isn't there I think if
you using a list activity for example
then you get the on item selectors
callback which will actually give you
the position as well so that's the
that's the index into your attacker but
I guess that applies to the whole row
doesn't it or mine yeah but you also get
a few diseases yeah sounds like a good
answer to me it's one of those you know
from my own part it's one of those why
would I want to know how to do that I
wouldn't want to do that but if I recall
correctly as well mr. Cyril ma ta of
Green droid fame did a series of really
really great blog posts about tips and
tricks on list views and I think this is
one of the topics we've covered about
how to have differentially kind of
separately clickable areas within a list
row and so I can either search for Cyril
mottier Android blog list view perhaps
or and we can try and put that link as
well sure actually I found it right here
that wasn't weak yeah it's it's a party
a list view tips and tricks number four
add several clickable areas that sounds
pretty close to me so hey URL can pop
that in the moderator perhaps his own
case who is it lost yeah in case button
from Poland isn't watching we should pop
that in the moderator as well Thank You
Cyril for writing that that great info
that's a pretty cool trick I must admit
yep use it responsibly like Sparky says
many times the better solution is to
have the whole list item clickable but
if there are separately like two actions
you want to have in the list item then
yeah I don't know exactly which row
which list you're referring to in in
Google Play client there are a few
perhaps it's the the new behaviours Evan
got that when you look at your list
all installed apps even now get rid of
stuff from that so all those apps which
you were just trying out honestly you
don't use the Taylor Swift app or
whatever you can now get it out of your
install history maybe that'll be an
example where you have a list item which
is mostly clickable and in a section at
the end which does secondary action cool
so unless we have any questions and what
do we do wrap up early get I want some
time back she shoot the breeze any more
questions
my just one little final thought
immersed in response to what you were
just saying about the secondary actions
I I just can't let that go without
suggesting also that there's there's
also perhaps and a fair argument to be
made for going with a long press rather
than having multiple clickable regions
other than that yeah I guess it comes
down to how discoverable you want the
action to be if you think it's not a
common enough use case to warranty
actually taking up to the space then
long press burying a nicer solution to
it yeah I must admit I hadn't even
considered the contacts that way yes
perfect or or you can make it you can
make it a checkable this state and then
you can check it and have and have an
action on the action bar or long press
to launch the protection action wise
it's pretty standard as well I quite
like just long press especially because
it lets you do like multiple selections
which I love and we talked about that
quite a lot yes they hunt and design in
action in case you missed it cool
all right well everyone gets 15 minutes
their day back how about that all right
well thanks everyone for tuning in it's
been our pleasure to talk Android
development with you and we look forward
to seeing you again at the next hangout
thanks everyone
thanks the good machines see